may record. Welcome to another Zoom call. If you worked with us last week or you have not
going on the member site, you'll see the announcements. We can do Cheekswap testing again.
We've updated the Cheekswap testing forms. We have a three pages of the member site. So make sure
you get on there. You can see the Cheekswap agreements, which we always had on there. You don't need
to look at that. The Cheekswap testing request form. I do remember some people are still
sending in Cheekswabs without any requests form. Then we have to call you and stuff. So please send
in that request form to make it easier. We've even made it an online form if you want. So people
can do it online right there as well. And then you can order more Cheekswabs and you can
link to pay for your testing right there as well. It just saves us. We have less staff.
And anything that can just take some pressure off our staff. That would be great. So if you can
link to pay for yourself right there. Order more Cheekswabs if you don't have any.
And the form if you want to print it and send it back with your Cheekswabs. Or if you just want
to do the form online, we've created that online form. Just trying to simplify. The other thing,
other is a new announcement or anything. But please only ask questions on the member's site
in the blue question box at the bottom. We occasionally still get people emailing questions in.
They won't will not be answered anymore. We just it just doesn't go. I don't see it and they don't
see it till afterwards. And it's just please just please ask the questions on the member's site.
If you want to write programming update, if you want to update your frequencies or if you think
you need them updated for any reason, fill out this Cheekswab test form and do it to be a Cheekswab
test. It's going to be better. So okay. Remember you all have access to all our courses. And remember
also that the that the search bar is on our member's site only now. It's not on our website anymore.
And our 900 pages and blogs. Your post is only accessible to members now, not to the general
public. So that's for you guys to look at. And if you have questions between these Zoom calls,
please do take a few minutes. It may have already been answered in a blog post. Okay.
Let's get to your questions. The protocol for chemotherapy says the day before chemo,
water fast, but continue supplements. Should I continue taking vitamin C, which is an antioxidant,
greens first in some spectrum? Are there supplements that should be avoided around chemo time?
Some that don't interfere with the chemo's ability to work most definitely. So the general rule with
chemo therapy and understand this is not really a rule. These are just suggestions because there's
some natural doctors that say forget it. You're not don't worry about not taking antioxidant
stirring chemo. I follow the idea that it makes sense not to take strong antioxidants while you're
doing chemo. No, understand. If you take antioxidants, let's say your chemo is, okay, so let's put
a scenario. Let's say your schedule is you have chemo at night AM Tuesday. That's your chemo IV.
So that's a chemo infusion at night AM on Tuesday. So should you stop taking antioxidants on Monday?
Well, really, your antioxidants are going to stay in your system. All your vitamin C has a half-life
in your system that's fairly short. That's a water soluble vitamin. It's not going to stay in your system
very long. We need the extra vitamin C that you took from you supplement. Antioxidants like
alpha-lopeic acid and stuff have some of them have a longer half-life. Some of them have a shorter
half-life. Resveratrol has a very short half-life, meaning that it's really out of your system. So
should you stop the taking any antioxidants a day before? You can, so optional. So you could stop
all antioxidants 24 hours before the chemo. In the chemo protocol, I just say don't take it
with that 48-hour window. So in this case of this example, that's why I wrote down that example.
You're not taking any antioxidants from two o'clock from night o'clock Tuesday morning
till not tell what say you got done with it. Let's say you finished the IV infusion. Let's say you
finished at 11 o'clock. So then you'd wait till you started at night o'clock. You finished at 11 o'clock
then you would wait till Thursday, which is 48-hour window that you would at when you finished
at 11 o'clock the Thursday that you would that these this is the window that you would stop doing
the antioxidants. You wouldn't do the coffee animals. You wouldn't do any really strong detox
things because you want the chemo to be in your system for that time. Could you start a day before
with that going off of all those? Yes, but remember when I said there's some natural doctors that
say forget it. You should be taking your antioxidants throughout that whole time that you're doing
chemo because it's really just protecting your healthy cells. It's not going to be protecting
your the cancer cells. So there's disputed that. There are no
studies that's you know either way that the chemo was more effective when people stopped their
antioxidant. There's never going to be a study because it's impossible to really measure that.
So it's just hypothetical based upon you know data that hey it doesn't make sense.
Chemo therapies are strong oxidizing agent why be taking antioxidants
during the chemo but again the opposing view is the antioxidants are only protected
your healthy cells and that's what will help protect your healthy cells. It helps you from having
you know help you to have less ill effects of the chemo therapy. So
um uh that's step number one. Let's step number two uh this question is okay might have
it see is a strong antioxidant um alphalopeic acid is a strong antioxidant. There's a number of other
ones. There's certainly antioxidants and greens first but I would not say that taking greens first
is a strong antioxidant. This is like eating a good diet. You don't stop eating a good diet
during chemo. Sun spectrum has curcumin in it which technically has some antioxidant properties
but I wouldn't stop taking sun spectrum. I wouldn't classify this as an antioxidant.
So really your antioxidants would be your vitamin C your alphalopeic acid um
flavonoids have some antioxidant property but I still would I wouldn't even stop taking that.
It's really those two biggies and then part of the chemo protocol is also to to stop
any um uh any excess you could say um liver detoxification and that would really just be don't do
and this is just within that 48 hour window right um you're not you're not doing
um uh coffee edemas you're not doing um castor oil packs and over your liver um things that's
the only thing that you're really stopping during that time. So that is really the chemo protocol
member. It's just a suggested protocol. There's people that think differently with that.
Now your oncologist thinks the whole opposite side of the spectrum which should stop taking all
your supplements if you're going to do his care you know from ground zero and you never take any
supplements that's just absolutely ridiculous. In an ingredients list is coconut sugar the same
as coconut palm sugar. Google search is not convincing one way or another thanks.
Well I'm not any better specialist at that either so I don't have the answer that I apologize.
I don't know the difference with coconut sugar and coconut palm sugar. I think either of the
sugars are acceptable um much healthier sugars for us but I don't know the difference between those
maybe somebody else here does. I've tried to decided to try an alternative to lettersol. So lettersol
is a robotase inhibitor which decreases bad estrogens, excuse me decreases all estrogens in your body
because my bones were aching my eyes were so red and dry and constant dry,
eye drops did not help. So when any medications have a lot of side effects to them and certainly
the side effect can be coming because it is a chemical that's affecting other things in your body
and the side effect can be coming because it is doing what it's actually intended to do which
and lettersol is meant to drop all estrogens down to an animal's stuffing and then you're
going to have side effects from not having estrogen because you're supposed to have estrogen.
Question goes on. I have a roba clear, astro clear and aloevia immune. So the aloevia
immune is not it has nothing to do with lowering estrogens. This is an immune stimulate polysaccharide.
These two products as well as as I've ordered so far as I'm so these two products and so far as I
will help lower bad estrogens. Since I'm using them as an alternative what is the recommended
amount I should take? Well the aroma clear typically I'd recommend two to three per day of these
and this also has to do the there's some caveats to these two it depends on you know if a person is
in relative remission then they can be unless if their cancer is growing then they want to be on more
and this is assuming that a person is either ERPR or HER2 positive. If your ER negative,
PR negative and HER2 negative what's called triple negative still there could be benefits to
taking these products because personally I don't necessarily completely trust their testing so
that astro clear is a linkedin product that I would take again about two to three per day and the
so far as I am is a broccoli product that's one of the clearest on the market. This can be really
effective not just to lower estrogen levels but it can actually be a cancer killer in a hormone
balance or as well and this one I would suggest at least for a day probably on this one and you
could go lots of time back with people on higher doses of sub fours on that and are there supplements
that should never be taken again? No you're not going to have any issues with any of those you could
take all those together. I've watched your video on Juicy the Brazilian Fuzzy and what I should do
according to my genetics so so I do have a video Juicy versus Blending if you haven't seen that you
can go it's probably on the member site it's certainly on our YouTube channel. There's positives
and negatives to both you see and blending so one of the things that I recommend based upon
genetics so we talk about genetics precondition to whether a person should juice or they should blend
has to do with the gene called the HIF1 gene so the HIF1 gene I have a video on it you can watch
I'd say the genetics read your genes course might also even be on the member site because the HIF1 gene
is important with cancer patients if you have a lot of defects in this gene it means that
you can your cancer can be fed it has a higher degree chance that it's fed that your cancer
is fed through glycolicis so if your cancer is fed by glycolicis that means it's using using glucose
so if it's using glucose to feed on you don't want to be juicing as much so juicing is taking out
all the fiber out of a food product and you're just getting the juice now the proponents of juicing say
that's the way to go you don't need all that fiber you could drink a whole lot more juice if the
fiber is removed so therefore you're putting it through a juicer there's different varieties
I'll get into that but then you are drinking that juice and an ingerson protocol you're drinking
you know anywhere between you know eight and 15 glasses of this juice a day that's a whole lot
of ounces of juice which is very concentrated any juice even vegetable juice even green juice is
going to have a lot of glucose but certainly if you're going to add carrots apple celery which is a
typical gertian type juice mixture to be very higher glucose if you've got a lot of HIF1 defects
chance that your cancer is using glucose as a fuel source is very high probably not a good idea
to juice oh well isn't aren't you getting the same amount of sugar when you blend well remember when
you measure your total numbers of grams of glucose that you're consuming in a given day you can
instantly subtract the grams of fiber that you're consuming so if I look at a product and the product
has six grams glucose and it has it has three grams fiber then I that I really only have
a total of three grams of total glucose because the fiber will attach to the glucose and it's the
same way with with blend it if you're blended you're getting all the fiber of the product as well
you're really offsetting the glucose you won't be able to drink nearly as much if somebody could drink
13 glasses of blended vegetables a day they would probably explode you can't do that so you'll drink
a whole lot less you're going to get fiber with it will help offset some of the glucose so if you have
HIF1 defects or have I've told you that you have to really be out of low sugar diet I would suggest
you know either doing a little bit of juicy not a lot of juicy or doing blendin
is it okay to remove the little rubberized clamps and I assume you're talking about these things on
the outside of your machine this is the F-117 this is the F-122 yes you can you could just unscrew
those these were these are to wrap the corner out if you're traveling it makes it easier also there
used to be a ground a handheld ground thing that you that would attach to that side on these units too
they don't use those anymore but you could remove those I've removed mine on the side of mine
so yes you can okay questions from the chat I have breast cancer my markers are going down
tumor seems to be shrinking but the breast is swollen I feel this is inflammation is there something
else I can be doing to reduce this so when you have any swelling remember it can be a good thing
because it can be your immune response to the area so the the I would it if I had breast cancer this
I would not put anything topically at it I would consider using flavonoids we talk about flavonoids
all the time here because it is so they are so they are your first go to for any type of swelling
inflammation great inflammation and that is the standard flavonoids so so if you have any type
of inflammation I help my daughter and son of law move last weekend that's why my throat is like this
just going in and out of the house I caught a little bit of a cold um but uh you know I'm not
a young chick anymore and doing the work of a 25-year-old um is can have taxied events on your
body so it is this is what I've been taking uh a lot of since uh this weekend these are anti-inflammatory
so egcg from green t-extract curcumin or as veratrol corsetin these are your flavonoids
these are things that everybody I think should be taking constantly because um their benefits to decrease
inflammation in your brain so want to stay young healthy keep a healthy brain you need to be
consuming tons of uh flavonoids what time of day is best to take them into some mushroom powder and
how and how much water so time of day is not as important um as um just you know as so some people say
you should take your supplements in the morning because you need to the energy through the day and there's
benefits to doing that especially if you're taking adaptogens to help balance your hormones and such
like that during the day to keep your energy up and yes you do do the nutrients to fuel your
body during the day but remember everything has a half line so isn't good to take you know all your
supplements at night well your body needs anti-inflammatories and nutrients at night things are still
happening at night yeah you're not burning energy via muscle tissue but your brain is still functioning
so there isn't a horrible you know reason there's not a giant reason why you shouldn't be taking
things before you go to bed except that they're they're just sitting in your stomach and capsules
can irritate your stomach um the best way what I used to tell people all the time with your with
your medicinal mushroom mix with sunscreen and greens first as I used to try to get people
to sip it uh for several hours because they have a half life and it's you know it'd be better to
spread things through the day so it'd be better to spread your supplements throughout the day
now the problem is is that most people will be like what I'm not going to just sip
carry this around and sip this all the time well the next best thing would be to break it into
several doses so and then you're taking a dose in the morning and a dose in the afternoon so you've
got an AM and PM dose schedule and that's the way it is best to take all your supplements the more
you could break them up the better because of that issue that you're going to lose them as you
burn them and as your body uses them throughout the day I'm not sure you're able to answer this but
at one point do you decide to stop conventional treatments oncologists said I would need to be an
eye branch the rest of my life even if the markers are at zero I'm trying to decide at one point
I would be smart to stop treatment I have a CT in bold scan in February he did tell us that he will
support us no matter what we do realize that he isn't familiar with supplements right
for emotional treatments etc yeah I can't answer that question that is a question that everybody has
to answer themselves but you pray for wisdom and you're seeking wisdom and let's say you scans come
up really well and it's like okay well there's nothing wrong with saying you know you know after you
prayed about it really sought an answer from God about it if you feel peace about stopping
something it doesn't mean you have to stop it forever you know you couldn't stop it you don't do
some retests in three months if your numbers go back up then you can go back on it so I don't think
there's anything wrong with with pausing things what is your opinion on taking zeolite so zeolite is
a binder slash key later so I don't have any trouble taking zeolite the only thing you have to
be careful with with any of the keylaters so a key later is something that will is a new nutrient that
grabs on to chemicals and heavy metals oh well I want to take that well you got to go back and you
guys all have access to my seven phases detoxification course highly recommend that you go through it or
at least skim through it because that will tell you that you know you have to make sure all the phases
of your detoxification pathways are open before you do chelation which is in my book phase zero
which is the last thing you would do well I'm doing all these other things I've already done all
I do detox all the time of good coffee animals okay that's great then maybe it is time for the
key later but there's several things that you really have to know you don't want to take any strong
keylaters if your if you have heavy metals in your mouth like mercury fillings so if you have mercury
fillings you never want to take strong keylaters so if you still have mercury fillings in your mouth
silver fillings then you can never take strong keylaters because you will just pull it out of your
mouth and put it into your body and that will not be a good thing second thing is is if you have a
metal implants so if you have metal implants in your body you just should never be on strong key
later so what's a strong key later so strong keylaters would be the EDTA and the MSDS M O
the MSO the MSA that's what was called those would be the strong keylaters so that would be it are
our key look clear which is our phase six I would not take that product can you take zero light
zero light would fall into a medium key later medium strength key later in my book you could probably
get by taking zero light with metal fillings or mercury fillings are dental implants or metal implants
but you know just don't overdose on it what are your thoughts on ammonia scavenger ammonia scavenger
we can't remember all the components of it but it's a great product to decrease ammonia in your
body especially have genetic tendencies to gather too much ammonia my understand correctly
still confused watching the video day before okay I just answered that question that was you
must have jumped on late so you could listen to that recording is keep one a good replacement for
Resvoxatrol good question so you if you need to get Resvoxatrol from us just call us we we can get
that we just can't have it on the store of the public site anymore or the molecular just change
their policies they don't let anybody sell online so if you we can still get that for you let me
look at what keep one is I can't remember what's in keep one I don't recommend it really that often
uh it uh yeah no it doesn't have any Resveratrol in it at all so um so no I would not say that that's
a substitute I'm considering doing hold of Clark's parasite cleanse since it's relatively inexpensive
and could hurt right one of the things she pushes hard is her zapper well her zapper is a
rife like tool that it's it's like it's you know it's like either you know with the true rife it's
like driving a Ferrari with the zapper it's like walking I mean it's that difference it's not even
I don't think it's even a rife so just use the parasite frequencies on your rife machine
so um I'm very you know big into using frequencies obviously and when hold of Clark created that zapper
that was leaving I think before true true rife existence so it was a long time ago that that's an
old piece of equipment but very a big fan of it so um use your rife and um you can certainly do your
do whatever nutritional protocol that she's recommending with her parasite cleanse you can also look
at our paraclyte parasite cleanse bundle that I put together if you're interested in that as well
could you prescribe kind of trips and a trips and along with my current digestive digestime to
continue to help decrease my tumor a kelly protocol so let me look at the particular enzymes in
these products if you'll give me a second no the answer the answer to your question is yes um
I just identified the product that would be the greatest concentration of those
so you have to give me some time because we have so many enzyme products on our store
but um stevia I can get back to you on that and let you know um uh what is the reasonable productive
amount of blended smoothie to consume in a day I think reasonable amount if you're drinking
32 to 40 ounces boy that's a lot that's an awful lot of fiber and that could get you bloated I would say
probably a maximum of maybe 12 ounces twice a day would be really a maximum
that's what I would say also depends on your weight um that's for me a pretty big guy you maybe
even less than two eight ounces glasses a day would probably be maximum I've had a low hum in my right
ear sense around Thanksgiving which I only notice when all is quiet is there any reason my dietary
or supplemental program would give me tenitis my weekly practitioner who muscle tests said it's from
the vaccination shedding others not me but I received from somebody else not me not sure if I should
be worried seeing a new oncologist on Friday what should I ask him to investigate further and
oncologist wouldn't investigate anything they would just send you to EMT doctor um
uh if so number one cause of tenitis is a reaction to a medication um number two cause of
tenitis is toxicity so tenitis is caused from um inflammation or placking on the
on the audio nerve and it isn't an easy fix because if there is placking on that nerve which is a
cranial nerve um it can be permanent so there are some you know tenitis fixes you might have seen on
Facebook it's up those they just do not work um nutritionally the biggest thing that I would say
that you'd want to help nutritionally that would help support it would be um the delta
total triadal which is the inside delta form of the vitamin E that's what's in a pop E that is actually
the that delta total triadal part of the vitamin E molecule is what helps um the inner ear it helps
the audio nerve it also helps your cranial vessels um your ear is is uh integrated by what's called
a terminal vessel i mean it doesn't have other vessels feeding it vascularly so oxygen um so a
terminal vessel is one that doesn't have what are called the dastamosid vessels that are also feeding
it the same thing is true with the vessels of your heart um certain parts of the heart are only fed
by one one vessel um and if you have a heart attack you don't have other you know vessels feeding
that and the heart can stop and cardio cells can die that's what a heart attack is um because you have
terminal vascularcher in the heart you also have it in the ear so that part of vitamin D the delta
total triadal is so good for those vessels so whatever i said number one cause of
tinnitus is a reaction to a medication which is basically a toxicity another number two is really
the same thing toxicity but you could also have um issues with hearing hearing loss and tinnitus
because of contraction of those terminal vessels so you actually have decreased oxygenation to
the tissues so delta total triadals and it's that's found in um uh the apop e the reason why i call
it apop e is because it helps promote apoptosis it's the vitamin E that helps promote apoptosis um and
it's been shown in multiple studies as a quote-unquote cancer killer because it helps support apoptosis
but it does so many things for your vessels as well so apop e is a great product for your heart
um why did i name it apop e because it's daily we seek cancer patients so we could uh we could
have named it like cardio e or something like that too because it is the type of vitamin E that you
want for your heart as well what do you think about s o t or d t where they take your blood cells
and trade them to attack your cancer um yeah we've had some patients go through s o t therapy there's a
clinic down in Florida there's one in Arizona i think that does it and there's some in Mexico that do it
um yeah you know i don't know um i had one person recently that
started it did several sessions and then stopped didn't think it was helping her um and i had
somebody do it about two years ago they thought it helped them but they were doing so many other things
too i don't know how they could have discerned that but you know i've heard good reports so yeah i
i'm not against doing these so one of these alternative things also i cut out sweets and just about
all sugar two years ago why is my hemoglobin A1c state of 1 5.6 and 5.7 in the past is always been lower
there's other factors with hemoglobin A1c not just your sugar consumption has to do with your cell
membranes and healing your cell membranes and that takes a lot longer time it has to do with um you know
so your insulin receptors on your cell membranes don't um don't change easily so and then
you know would you increase insulin receptors on your cell membranes because of a bad diet or
a long period time that's the problem with diabetes type two is that you got somebody with type two
diabetes and you think oh it's just an easy fix you're just going to go on a complete no sugar no
carb diet and that's going to fix your problem and people can't figure out why it doesn't fix their
diabetes they still have elevated glucose levels um it's because you're you've damaged your cell
membranes and as that cell replicates a new cell it replicates a new cell with that same amount
of insulin receptors on it so that's really the issue it's a cell membrane issue and it just takes
a long time to move that needle but taking clear corseted powder one scoop seems to
amp me up is this common um corseted is a flavonoid so it's going to decrease inflammation your
brain and by doing that it could actually increase your brain power so um it's you know it also
is going to increase your blood flow so anti-inflammatory is going to decrease inflammation at your at your
vascular level as well so it's going to increase the blood flow to your brain if you need to spread that
out just take a half a scoop in the morning half a scoop at night again like any other supplement
that's good to spread it out. Are you familiar with Linda Isaac's protocol so Linda Isaac
is who used to work oh she right here she worked with Dr. Gonzalez started her own practice while she
had her she had a practice with Dr. Gonzalez who a Dr. Gonzalez passed away she basically took it over
so I believe that her protocol is still using um you know much of Dr. Gonzalez's protocol in his
enzyme therapies and yeah I think enzyme therapy could be a great protocol especially for colorectal
liver and pancreatic cancers question about chemo was also regard to diet resume the diet the day after
chemo if so any particular time of day does it depend on when to finish the infusion so as far as
fasting so the chemo protocol and then fasting um uh yes so what we say in the chemo protocol you
you fast the daily work chemo so 24 hours so if your chemo infusion is at nine o'clock Tuesday morning
like in this um example then you would start fasting nine o'clock Monday morning and then as soon as
you come home from chemo infusion then you could eat 150 pounds that's related to your the question
back here um let it slowly I'd say you know probably eight to 12 ounces of the morning at
eight 12 ounces of the afternoon my weight dropped at 96 in order to gain weight I thought I would
try Kate Farms do you think this is uh do you like this as a calorie drink well it is a cleaner calorie
drink for sure but always what you want to gain weight you want to um make sure that you are
you're adding some carbs back to your diet so I have if you go to the um that little thing
the member site uh in search for cakexia uh and you'll be able to see some ideas that I have uh
there what to do for cakexia I mean you weight loss you're not i mean cakexic state
unless you're technically losing two to four pounds a week though whatever what you're eating
but still if you're trying to gain weight you need to add some complex carbohydrates back to your diet
Pam said her enzymes one pill includes amylase peptase trips and okay I'll have to look at that
and see I noticed a video sent on testing and taking so many supplements overwhelms and liver what
type of testing that will be the the cheek swab test about across roads to what I really need to do for my
body uh nodes are stable but some progression at the bone not having bone pain or transformation at all
previous emailment and do uh wants another pet scan in march and setting up to go to the pro novo
scan so that's great we talked about that pro novo scan so yes I would just go back and do another
cheek swab test so we can check anything that we need to tweak on that after using pancreatic tenex with
grypsin and chymotrypsin in one capsule from professional formulas um so that's uh we have that product
on our store I'll show you right here um so she's talking about this product right here
so that does have a lot a hundred thousand forty thousand thank you for that appreciate that
uh it says if this is good how many a day would be effective um well again that's going to be
different than on your weight depending up on your type of cancer depending on your body type
some people you know but take you know if person has pancreatic cancer they're trying to deal with that
you're still going to be taking ten of these in the morning ten of the afternoon at least five to ten
and uh right before you go to bed on the empty stomach so that's the idea of um
enzyme therapy you're taking that empty stomach you're not trying to use enzymes to digest your food
you're trying to get your body to absorb the enzymes so that enzymes can digest the waist layer
around the cancer any comments at MMS so MMS is a miracle mineral supplement um it's also called um
chlorine dioxide it's the same thing um I think it's a great product we used to use it
all the time with our lying patients we used to see a lot of lying patients I've said that before
we used to use MMS all the time with our lying patients it worked great and they do have a cancer
protocol as well um to be I have a really hard time um with all when MMS came out they were basically
it was sold like snake oil and they would claim it cured everything and I really really have a
difficult time with any company that does that that in fact you could probably find the video on
light where I don't know if it was 2020 or date light or 60 minutes or something stuck into one uh um
the guy who started MMS his name was nice name was humble stuck into one of his meetings and
videotape his meetings and it was just embarrassing pretty nutritional salesperson because they
claimed that it was basically grown in limbs and um so I have a hard time with any company that does
that so I really struggle with MMS that way from an emotional standpoint but getting over that I think
it can be really really helpful in killing um in direct killing bacteria and other um fungus and
parasites so I think there can be benefits to it hugely with that I just really struggle with why
it would help cancer um it just doesn't make any physiological sense to help with cancer
makes all physiological sense to help with um infectious disease so MMS for like COVID MMS for
any type of viral parasite bacterial um live disease type thing yes I think it could be very
very helpful do I have enough of the delta toco triadles in the immune packs for my tenitis
um wondering if all the detoxing triggered tenitis uh possibly that could be the detoxing
um stress that could trigger tenitis tell you that right now because what a stress do it
contracts the vessels so if you already have some plaque into the vessels on a terminal vessel
that's going to make it worse um the immune packs so let me search that real quick and uh uh forgot
what's in there oh so that has that has that 80k it has delta toco triadles in the D that is in there
um baby baby that's enough and you know that's certainly a good supply for your heart
if you're having conditions specific issues sometimes you want to ramp it up on that on the
delta toco triadles but um I'm not saying that that is your tenitis issue there is also a
tenitis program on the right if I'd suggest trying we've had people that said it helped
after how many years of clean eating do you think it's safe to cut back on gut healing supplements
or possible to muscle tests yes yep I mean you the thing is is that you already you got to remember
that you always are damaging your gut so even if you're eating clean you're still getting pesticides
and herbicides you're still getting GMOs the worst thing that damages your gut if you go out to eat
your certainly getting GMOs that are so damaging to your gut so I by cutting back I would say to
pulse them so instead of oh I'm gonna go to last I would stay on the same dose but then maybe take
go two weeks on two weeks off or you know a week out a week off or I'm gonna go Monday through
Friday and not take them on the weekend something like that that's what I would do how much beef
heart is too much in a month to eat um is your question beef heart H-E-A-R-T I'll let you
answer that on this I know exactly what you're talking about what is your opinion on taking CBD
and THC oil so there is literally no downside to CBD I haven't even heard of anybody that has a
sensitivity to CBD so there's no downside to CBD CBD can be can act like a flavonoid as far as
anti-inflammatory goes it can be good for the brain it can be calming for the brain CBD has
those benefits but CBD is not like um like a pain reliever like I'm just gonna take the CBD and my
pain's gonna go away similar than if I took a Tylenol or an Advil of THC on the other hand is the
psychotropic type of uh in the of the cannabinoids and that's what's going to give you the high so
THC has some negatives it has some downsides it's going to make you feel loopy THC in a low dose
can be really good for just helping you sleep helping with anxiety helping with stress
if you're taking high dose in what you just said reg symptoms in oil or what's said RSO
so that's the high dose CBD so it's boiled down it's distilled down so this pasted it's like a it's
comes in a syringe and it's very tar like uh if you put it on your finger and you have to literally
scrape it off uh of your of your finger what's your tooth because it's that tarry like
very high concentration and that is what is used for a cortical cancer killing protocol
I am very much a fan of it very much a fan of it if you can tolerate it okay so
I took RSO and a number of years ago when I was really doing really poorly
I was willing to give it a try holy cow you know I'm kind of you know I've never smoked a cigarette or
you know got drug you know I've been just lived kind of a uh kind of a clean life that way
I really reacted to RSO um I took too much of it to begin with that was the problem and it became a
really funny story around the office but besides that I don't want to get too deep into that
it I just I had to go off for a while and I tried to go back out it it just makes me really loopy
I just don't feel good with it so everybody's a little bit different so I would if you're going to
try that I'd highly suggest trying it and don't try away from it but go slow just go slow under your
dose now typically in RSO protocols you start with one grade of rice three times a day that's too much
for that would be way too much for me it might be too much for you um so I would say you would go
start slower than that can we take lesser capsules of the of the paper absolutely yes you can it's
always good to start slow on anything so um good question yeah I think it's good to start slow
you're still going to get benefit I mean literally with enzymes you can not go wrong with enzymes
period nobody can so they're so good for you or so deficient to them because our our
pancreas are so hyper stressed these days really can't go wrong with enzymes
so talking beef heart so is there downside to having too much beef heart um well
there's a question this nobody's ever asked me before so eating or animal organ meat you have to
be careful of a couple things you want to get them as clean as possible meeting that you know the
source that that that organ meat is clean there there those those beef cattle were out on a field
that was never sprayed they're eating organically because your organs will pick up the majority of
your toxins ultimately even more so than the muscles so we try to eat organic hamburger right or
organic chicken but then we're not eating you know really clean source organic organ meat that's a
bigger mistake so make sure if you're eating beef heart like because you're growing your old beef and
you're eating beef heart you're eating you know that that you know that the source and it's clean
secondly what's the benefit of eating beef heart well be the eating organ meat can be the most
nutritious for a person so if a person has a heart problem eating beef heart would be really good for
you but even short of that it's still going to be a good source protein for a person as well I don't
think there's a downside of eating too much I you know I don't I don't I guess I don't know that much
about the the fat equivalent in beef heart and such like that to answer that fully but an organ meat
can be really good for us if we have a good clean source I had a new CT scan today with contrast
it appears that there was no new findings and I am stable that's fantastic I see my oncologist on Friday
for the full review one line in the CT says stable mild sclerosis along the right anterior fifth
rim near the cost of cartilage junction no new lesion so what how do you explain that stable means
it hasn't become any worse mild is mild moderate and severe that's how a radiologist really reads
anything sclerosis is build up a bone on a bone so a sclerotic bone is it increase calcium laydown
of the bone along the right the right side anterior front fifth rib near the costo cartilage costo
means rib cartilage is the cartilage so your ribs in the front don't attach directly to the sternum
they attach through this cartilage it's called your costo cartilage and the junction there
so it's probably out about two inches from your sternum on the right side your fifth rib down
that's where the sclerosis was so when you have sclerosis of a bone it can be because of
arthritic sclerosis could be because of an old injury it could be because of an old break it can
be because of in sclerosis in a joint is bad because that's arthritic usually degenerative sometimes
inflammatory arthritis that causes sclerosis and it's going to cause issues in the joint you're
going to have pain and swelling and such if it's in the bone itself it can be because of an old
injury if you've got hit the chest with a softball you could have sclerosis there but you could have
also sclerosis after the testesis of cancer to the bone that your bone is now healing so the
sclerosis would actually be a good side of healing bone so so remember I said almost all the
metastasis cancer metastasis the bone is going to be lytic eating the bone is being eaten away
and radiologists may use phrases like moth eaten or rat bite lesion those are all radiology
terms used for lytic erosion loss of bone that is always pathological meaning that it is always
from a disease so sclerosis can become not can be non-pathological sclerosis it can be from an
injury like I've mentioned or it can be pathological sclerosis that's healing from a lytic lesion
from cancer your body is healing that where can you get good RSO oh boy it's available in lots of
different ways now there's so many states that it's legal in so you can check in the legal
states at a supplier and look at RSO there's also RSO groups on Facebook and telegram so I would
search those where people have trusted sources of RSO is your CBD oil 2000 milligrams the same as RSO
no not even close CBD and and THC are completely completely different so no the CBD 2000 milligrams has
no THC we don't sell any CBD that has THC and we can't legally do that if given the choice what's
better to do or doesn't matter a CT plus bone skin or pet skin I don't know if my new oncologist
will want me to do a follow up or what my insurance will cover I think a pet skin's probably better
but you're if your oncologist says no I think the CT bone skin then have him tell you why so he'll
give you a reason why is metastatic bone disease save as metastasis metastasis is a metastatic
movement so metastasis is when cancer spreads to another place in the body if it spreads to the bone
then it's called metastasis to the bone or metastatic bone disease or they may describe it as
metastatic lesions in the bone there's a lot of different ways to describe it so if a metastasis is
to the bone it's metastatic it's metastatic to the bone if a metastasis metastasis to the liver
than it's metastasis to the liver remember wherever metastasized let's say if you have colorectal
cancer a metastasized to the bone it's that bone cancer it's colorectal cancer in the bone
If it metastasizes to the liver, you don't have liver cancer, no, you have metastatic colorectal cancer to the liver.
A little confusing, but it's the cells that break off.
If you just think of it that way, the cells are breaking up, looking for a place to set up another home, so they're the same types of cell.
Good might excess green smoothie drinking be causing weight gain.
Probably not.
There's enough calories in your greens smoothie to cause weight gain.
I'd say no.
Can AST and ALT liver test show if the liver is congested or not?
Well, if your AST and ALT are elevated, then certainly that's the first thing you think of is liver congestion or liver toxicity.
So, would you say liver congestion? You're really talking about toxicity to the liver.
And the number one cause of that is the medication.
Okay, with that, I think we will say good night for the night.
Thank you for being on and we will talk again next week.
I have a blessed week.
And I'll be praying for all of you. Bye bye.